So there was a very interesting
article in "Fast Company"
recently that talked
about the fact
that people who were raised
bilingual, multicultural,
tended to have a more fluid
kind of creativity going.
And the reason is
because they were
familiar with
multiple mindwares,
multiple cultural
reality tunnels.
[SPEAKS SPANISH]
But on the other side, I
learned English very young.
I lived in the United States.
My mother has an
American family.
I grew up a secular Jew.
There is that world view.
There is that mindware.
And having to move
between worlds
allowed me to see just how
ambiguous everything is,
and just how fluid
everything is.
And so that makes
you, I think, more
open to connect the
dots in a new way,
more open to different world
views, more open to the reality
is tightly coupled
to perception,
and perception is tightly
coupled to our cultural reality
tunnel.
Perception is
essentially linguistic.
The world is made of language.
Reality is kind of
written into being
inside of these cultural
mindware environments
in which we live.
And so in order to deal
with violence, in order
to practice tolerance,
in order to fix
the maladies of
the world, we first
need to realize just
the fact that all of us
are living in
different universes,
different cultural world views.
And I think understanding
that and leveraging
that insight might allow
us to find a way to connect
more deeply with one another.
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]